so it's pretty obvious that a 3d printer
is super applicable to engineers
industrial designers and architects you
know those those folks see a MakerBot
they see the price tag and they just
take out their credit card and it's
shipped to them in a couple days and and
it's just a no-brainer it gets
interesting though when you when people
who aren't necessarily in a maker
culture and engineering culture or
design culture get it because in many
ways they're free to do anything every
single person gets a drug like rush when
you when they fix something or they make
something from scratch even if it's like
you know a mashed potato casserole you
still get a rush when you make it and
it's in and it's yours so in growing a
company that had a real connection to a
maker spirit we were we were tapping
into something that humans had set to
the side for the last hundred years and
so it allowed us to basically light up
those you know vestigial parts of our
humanity and celebrate them and I think
that's a frankly our biggest challenge
as a culture is is how do we empower
people to unlock their true potential
and explore who they are because you
know I just I believe that inside each
person is the potential to have deep
deep powerful impact on their local
community and society at large so how do
we make that happen how do we unlock
that as I think about what kind of
advice I would give to other
entrepreneurs when they start I would
say it's actually better to to box
yourself in and create some a rule set
for yourself a manifesto something that
basically says we are going to live our
lives this way this is our criteria this
is our sort of limitations these are our
these are the things that is the this is
the sort of a challenge we're going to
give ourselves to stay within these
parameters probably the downside of this
is you end up sort of Europe you're
basically a fanatic
you're limited by what you've limited
what you can do you're sort of living is
in your own in your own person I am
living in my own personal cult at this
point right and the great thing is that
gives you an amazing focus and amazing
ability to make decisions because okay
does it meet your criteria yes or no
okay no screw it we're not doing that
there's so much there are so many places
that that that are just waiting for
innovation you know I'm in the hospital
and I'm like this is garbage here like
these this equipment costs too much is
too hard isn't streamlined as soon as
like has crappy you I bad user
experience and sure enough like and
people die if and people die because of
it so I'm like okay we can't like so
much opportunity in that and I just look
around the world and all I see is
opportunity for people to have a deep
impact on the world and make it better